et nous recevons ce matin camille
morineau bonjour bonjour merci d'être
avec nous vous êtes commissaire de
l'exposition pionnière artistes dans le
paris des années folles qui débute le 2
mars au musée du luxembourg à paris vous
êtes aussi conservatrice du patrimoine
et directrice de work eyes of woman
artistes exhibition association dont le
but est de promouvoir des artistes
femmes alors cette exposition elle est
consacrée à une période bien précise les
années va autrement dit les années
folles tout se passe à paris à ce moment
là une époque où les artistes femmes ont
toute leur place ont la parole elle ose
enfin j'ai envie de dire pourquoi est-ce
que c'est arrivé à ce moment là ça veut
dire que les mentalités étaient prêtes à
accueillir justement des femmes comme ça
qui s'affirme et enfin oui à un faisceau
de circonstances en fait c'est la fin de
la guerre qui a tué beaucoup d'hommes il
ya 700 milles veuve
en france par exemple et c'est aussi un
moment où politiquement plein de choses
se passent le droit de vote commencent à
arriver aux états unis en angleterre les
femmes s'émancipent est effectivement
paris est la capitale de cette
avant-garde féminine qui va absorber en
fait des femmes du monde entier de
l'europe de l'est des états unis
de l'inde du brésil qui viennent à paris
se former cette époque les femmes à sont
reconnus comme des artistes à part
entière ça c'est important de le
souligner parce que c'est vrai qu'avant
tout était consacrée aux hommes et pas
du tout aux femmes elles possèdent leur
atelier leur maison d'édition c'est une
petite révolution ou même une grande
révolution c'est une assez grande
révolution parce que ce moment là la
durée peu de temps il a duré dix ans et
les années 30 vont complètement faire
oublier cette période assez
extraordinaire où les femmes tiennent le
haut du pavé elles sont puissantes elles
sont connues elles passent à la
télévision comme tamara de lempicka qui
passe aux actualités elles gagnent bien
leur vie en faisant de la peinture des
arts décoratifs donc c'est un moment
tout à fait unique dans l'histoire de
l'art justement un mot de tamara de
lempicka on la sait très impliqué les
femmes osez ans et a enfin assumé leur
bisexualité ou leur homosexualité
et comme tamara de lempicka alors je
pense qu'on va le voir aussi alors ça
c'est évidemment un tableau d'elle il y
à son câble les deux amis parlez nous en
oui alors c'est un tableau qui semble
assez extraordinaire pour nous dans les
années 2020 mais qui n'était pas
tellement dans les années 1920 qui
représente deux femmes visiblement
amante maîtresse amoureuses l'une
d'entre elles est nu et on voit les
poils de son pubis qui est tout à fait
révolutionnaire dans les années 20 en
fait dans les années 20 l'homosexualité
était tout à fait acceptée relativement
public et pour les femmes plus que pour
les hommes et assumée vraiment et là
c'est assumer tamara de lempicka aimait
les femmes elle avait d'ailleurs
beaucoup de maîtresses l'une d'entre
elles et suzy solidor qu'on voit là une
chanteuse de cabaret très célèbre et
dont elle a fait le portrait nu donc
c'était quelque chose qui était
voilà qui était assumée dans la société
ce qui n'est pas forcément le cas
aujourd'hui il y à aussi à cette époque
on parle beaucoup du du troisième genre
claude cahun à oeuvrer dans ce sens
notamment à travers ses autoportraits
oui claude cahun c'était une photographe
extraordinaire qui s'est prise en photo
avec sa campagne qui s'appuyait suzanne
malherbe seller sorte d'autoportrait
très travaillée où elle va se travestir
mais à chaque fois on note qu'elle
allait les cheveux très courts donc elle
joue sur une sorte de genre entre le
masculin et féminin elle explique
d'ailleurs qu'elle préfère le genre
neutre ce qui là aussi résonne vraiment
avec les années 2020 un siècle avant
donc finalement cette fluidité des
genres elle a été inventée il ya un
siècle
homo également de suzanne valendons
emilie charmilles mais l'amateur ces
femmes qui n'hésitait pas à peindre des
femmes nues à faire des autoportraits ça
aussi c'est assez révolutionnaire pour
l'époque alors ce qui est intéressant
pour ses nus c'est que jusqu'ici les
femmes nues étaient représentés par des
hommes avec un regard érotique est les
femmes s'emparent du nu et forcément
elles vont faire autre chose elle se
représente chez elle un peu en mode
cocooning relaxe
sans forcer le trait telles qu'elles
sont plutôt quelquefois âge et pas
forcément joli pas forcément maquiller
donc c'est une typologie de nuque est
tout à fait nouvelle et qui va aussi
s'intéresser aux femmes pas forcément
bourgeoise aristocrate comment les
femmes vivent leur intimité chez elle
quelques fois avec leurs enfants pas
forcément contente d'être mère donc
c'est plein de choses nouvelles qui se
passe dans la représentation du nu ses
45 femme peintre sculptrice photographes
ont joué un rôle essentiel dans le
développement des grands mouvements
artistiques moderne et vous à travers
justement cette exposition vous leur
redonner leur place légitime absolument
cette exposition montre que les femmes
ont fait partie de toutes les âmes en
garde parisienne et internationale le
cubisme le fauvisme
de l'art décoratif l'abstraction
évidemment elle était quasiment à l'égal
des hommes dans ces années 20 et puis
les années 30 les ont oubliées donc
c'est vraiment un mouvement exceptionnel
et on voit qu'elles ont été moderne
autant que les hommes comment est ce
qu'on a pu finalement passer à côté de
cette période pendant un certain temps
alors malheureusement l'histoire des
femmes c'est un peu une histoire de
l'oubli c'est ce que travail
l'association world dont je suis
directrice rang visible ces artistes
femmes qui ont été oubliés tout au long
du xixème et du xxème siècle avec des
moments de visibilité comme les années
20 et des moments d'oubli comme les
années 30 les années 40 et jusqu'aux
années 60 en réalité quand on voit cette
exposition on voit aussi que eh bien
vous permettez aussi à certaines femmes
moins connus finalement dans le paysage
moins connue que de lempicka par exemple
et bien d'être présente et on va pouvoir
les découvrir au mieux de luxembourg
tout à fait il ya un mélange d'artistes
très connus comme tamara de lempicka
marie laurencin et puis des artistes qui
sont des découvertes y compris pour moi
spécialiste de l'histoire des femmes
j'ai fait des découvertes
extraordinaires comme mail à müstair qu
est une peintre d'origine polonaise qui
s'installe à paris qui vit très bien de
ces portraits là aussi assez célèbre et
qu'on a complètement oublié alors vous
parlez de votre association que vous
avez cofondé aware au kaiser romaine
artistes research and exhibition donc
c'est une association dont le but est de
promouvoir les artistes femmes on est en
2022 quel bilan vous tirez est-ce que
vous avez l'impression que ça y est
l'artiste femme elle a trouvé sa place
aujourd'hui où il ya encore pas mal de
travail il ya encore pas mal de travail
voilà on à 850 biographies d'artistes
sur notre site mais on pourrait en avoir
le double triple voire cinq fois plus
donc c'est un travail de redécouverte
qu'il faut continuer à faire et je pense
que si les jeunes artistes d'aujourd'hui
ont une vie un petit peu plus facile il
ya vraiment une histoire à réécrire
quand on découvre notamment cette
exposition ce livre on voit que vous
avez organisé cette exposition en neuf
chapitres est ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer justement découvre au fur et à
mesure et c'est ce qu'on découvrait
rebond sans tout dévoiler évidemment de
l'exposition parce qu'on va inviter tous
ceux qui sont à paris évidemment à y
aller si vous pouvez déjà nous donner
peut-être quelques indices oui tout à
fait alors vous m'avez posé des
questions très juste sur quelques
thématiques c'est une exposition qui pas
chronologique qui va
explorer certains thèmes on voit
notamment à l'écran une oeuvre de deux
tarsila do amaral qui vient du brésil et
il ya une salle par exemple intéressante
on se rend compte que ces artistes
femmes et se sont beaucoup intéressés à
la diversité ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui la diversité à la
présentation d'autres races tarsila do
amaral vie au brésil donc une population
noire et this elle va représenter cette
population est inventé une modernité
brésilienne donc c'est un des chapitres
de l'exposition ya effectivement une
salle sur le nu vous l'avez cité une
salle soit ce troisième genre qui est
entre deux eaux entre le masculin et le
féminin il ya une salle sur
l'abstraction voilà je vais pas tout
dévoiler mais beaucoup de surprises dans
cette exposition une exposition rythmée
par des chansons aussi puisque les
beaucoup de ces artistes sont chanteuses
et vont parler par exemple de
l'homosexualité ou de la garçonne qui
est cette mode des cheveux courts qui
est inventé dans les années d'ailleurs
on voit de joséphine baker reçu il ya du
rosé fine baker absolument alors c'est
un petit peu ça sera une des surprises
de l'exposition parce que joséphine
baker et l'artiste qu'on connaît
extraordinaire mais elle a aussi inventé
ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui le nem
branding faire de son nom une marque
elle avait inventé une brillante in pour
les cheveux des costumes des boucles
d'oreilles tout un tas de produits
dérivés portant son nom ce qui est assez
extraordinaire pour l'époque et elle
gagnait très bien sa vie merci beaucoup
camille morineau d'avoir été avec nous
je rappelle que cette exposition est à
découvrir à partir du 2 mars et jusqu'au
18 août jusqu'au 10 juillet ce sera au
musée du luxembourg à paris